hi everyone yeah
gave
gahafer after lunch talk or everybody
has full bellies and is ready to learn
uh so welcome to I talk CSS algorithms
my name is Laura and this is Version
three point six point one of my talk it
debuted last year last June 2018 at CSS
conquer Europe and after my talk I was
having some Aperol spritz us with people
in Berlin and they were like you should
submit this to Strange Loop now I was
like whoa strange that would take a CSS
talk but here I am yeah okay so let's
get right into it before we talk about
algorithms we need to settle something
is CSS so programming language fire
emoji so how many of you seem kind of
related conversation or drama about this
at some point in your career slash the
past year on Twitter okay me too so I
asked this question on Twitter when I
first started researching for this talk
it sounds like why do I feel like CSS is
not a programming language let me see
what Twitter thinks about this so
results are in no all right so this is a
very small data set of 129 votes but I
asked this question again when I started
giving this talk this year in May of
2019 and I was like oh everybody knows
your schtick Laura nobody's gonna
everybody like yes it's programming
language it's all your talk whatever no
I asked us again the nose the nose went
up not only that there were 5,000 about
5,300 votes this time it smells like
whoa okay this was really worth digging
into and the comments and responses were
so varied so there were answers like yes
of course what else is it and then
things like you can't really call
styling a webpage programming and then
answers that were like stop asking this
question don't wake the Beast like
everybody's everybody's happy so let's
stop and ask ourselves what is a
programming language before we decide
whether or not CSS is one of these
things so
as many of us the strangers were
probably aware there are a lot of
programming languages and there are
entire fields of research devoted to
this so a programming language can be
generally boiled down to a formal
language for instructing computer
computer to perform tasks so it's kind
of paraphrase from Wikipedia some other
sources but the range of programming
languages is so broad we can't have a
specific definition the key point is
language grammar syntax and kind of one
level deeper beneath what is programming
language we have all kinds of
programming languages there are
programming paradigms so the two main
paradigms imperative where you write
code that describes tells a computer how
to do something and declarative where
you say what to do so kind of the logic
is baked into the statements themselves
and there's the presence and absence of
control flow so the order of the ability
to manipulate the order of execution of
statements so in declarative programming
you say everything in a single statement
and that logic is kind of baked into the
statement itself what could possibly be
some programming languages that fall
under these categories imperative so
common languages general-purpose
languages oftentimes JavaScript Ruby C++
Python declarative languages are often
not always but often domain-specific
because they kind of require that
imperative backbone like that logic has
to exist somewhere so we have sequel
which is a domain-specific declarative
programming language for databases HTML
domain-specific declarative programming
language for adding meaning to content
on a web page and of course CSS language
for styling that content on a web page
so CSS is a domain-specific declarative
programming language 100% CSS
programmers program the layout of web
pages let's be honest boxes
100% everything is a box on the web box
programmers okay cool you're probably
like okay Lara great thanks yes this
program I need you cool so like so what
like what are we concerned about this
kind of meta definition of something but
like what's going on in here
ah what's happening so of course one
explanation is like Twitter a can of
worms slash opinions of course but I
think it maybe boils down to the fact
that we all kind of have our own
subjective definitions for what a
programming languages and what
programming is so what is the
programming language oh the answer is
well I think so we kind of have
internalized our own definitions for
what this is but once again so like who
cares everybody has their own
definitions of programming languages how
is this impacting my day-to-day life
well I have an answer for you let's talk
about something I would like to call
turd driven development okay so of
course this is a riff on test-driven
development and in test-driven
development you kind of start with an
assumption that all code is crap the
first time you write it like any code
you write no matter how brilliant of a
programmer you are it's gonna be crap
the first time you read it so you start
instead with write instead of writing
production code you start writing a test
first
so you write a failing test and then you
break code to make that test pass with
CSS and with you our programming we
don't necessarily have testing like that
yet but so our test for these these
purposes is the design so here's the
designer test it's automatically failing
because it doesn't exist so what do we
do to get the test to pass we write some
CSS okay so it's the first time we wrote
it it's crap then what do we do we stop
kind of wait some time goes by and then
oh look the test is failing
a new feature a new feature okay so what
do we do we go back and we write more
CSS okay
Oh test is feeling maybe there's some
kind of regression so what do we do then
to fix that
aggression right more CSS and then okay
everything works don't touch it time
goes by Oh new feature more CSS
regression more CSS and then our nicest
kind of red and green dot becomes not as
green anymore because the production
application no longer looks like the
design because we have all of the CSS
just kind of piling up forever and so we
never get our tests to pass and this is
the web this is a big problem and this
doesn't just apply to CSS this applies
to accessibility to the markup to the UI
of our web pages when we write code like
this bad news so what do we do ah this
is so bad it's so bad
okay stop writing CSS start programming
we have to think about CSS as a
programming language so for this talk
let's kind of look at some of these
definitions and how CSS fits into this
and then we can think about writing
algorithms in CSS so definition number
one here's our first friend what is a
programming language I think a
programming which is turing-complete
okay so Alan Turing 1936 the inventor of
the Turing machine which is a
hypothetical machine I can compute
anything anything theoretically
foundation of all modern devices all
modern digital devices also need to
mention Joan Clark is someone who worked
with Alan Turing potentially after I
think after the Turing machine paper she
was a code breaker at Bletchley Park in
World War two and I think it's worth
mentioning like her work and the work of
many others is also the foundation of
modern digital devices so Alan Turing
gets a lot of credit we had recognized
everyone else here so something is
Turing complete if it has a language
considered Turing complete if it has
conditional branching so if else
conditionals and infinite memory so also
the undecidability kind of prone to
undecidability so these algorithms that
will never terminate if anything really
is infinite memory so hypothetical
machine here's what the Turing machine
and I imagine
look like so I'll read write head some
infinite tape here and so when we're
talking about languages being Turing
complete we also need to mention
cellular automata they might have seen
cellular automata before Conway's Game
of Life it's kind of a common one so the
elementary cellular automata are a
little simpler than that and the rule
110 is shown to be a train complete
model for a machine so it's said that if
a language can program a rule 110 and
try and complete here is rule 110 so we
have this kind of code of rules and
start with some initial cell values take
three of them here and that determines
what the third the next one the next row
is and so we can kind of go through and
generate this rule 110 according to
these cells okay cool
so let's look at this in imperative and
declarative languages imperative if cell
one is one if cell two is zero and
Selleck steamers three is zero cell four
is one declarative we have something
like that so we're expressing what not
how so instead of assigning the value of
cell four to one we kind of select it
and so this is how we could do that with
CSS um but the trick is we got to tell a
human to change the state so we can use
inputs and CSS to track the state here
we can actually update that state in CSS
language so here you have rule 110 and
HTML CSS in human
okay okay the idea so CSS plus HTML plus
user this is cherry and complete this is
a very powerful very powerful trifecta
and also kind of based on the talk this
morning the keynote this morning I was
like oh this is kind of like
human-in-the-loop like except languages
like a human is part of the program
execution here that's pretty cool okay
what are some other things that are
turing-complete well sequel programming
for databases Excel spreadsheet
programming fairly and I showed us that
at the keynote before yesterday also
pokemon yellow apparently exploiting
game bugs you can build a Turing machine
minecraft Magic the Gathering
okay are these programming languages
Pikachu okay so our friend here well I
think programming will just try and
complete we can kind of respond with
like hmm along with HTML and user input
CSS is turing-complete
also pokemon yellow is turing-complete
and they'll be like fun facts thank you
and then you can say does that mean
pokemon yellow is a programming language
too and then they'll be like okay bye
done with this conversation okay next
friend what is a programming language I
think a programming language has
consequences mmm interesting okay what
consequences with CSS possibly they have
let's take some boxes pretty simple
program so I'm gonna do some silent
square programming here and kind of let
you all read the code as I flip through
okay cool I've got a nice little square
system there so the product Department
they're like okay front-end developer
we're gonna we're interested in getting
in the market of circles now and we run
around some a/b tests and the circle is
the same size as the other square so we
thought probably really easy for you to
do so go ahead and do that okay product
okay nice
oh okay so trying out some different
colors now
okay so everybody's loving my shapes so
far they're like are oh you're doing
such a great job and we really want to
try out some some different different
dimensions here oh okay I'm like all
right I've got a pretty robust system I
think I can handle this
who got that done
they're like oh my god we just realized
we can make buttons everybody's making
buttons now we got to put text in it
like this is the thing I'm like oh my
god okay okay all right
whatever you say oh okay got it done so
now some stakeholder comes down with
their gavel and says we need an icon aha
already hey this is so smelly what's
happening so this is true driven
development everyone yes so this is what
happens I'm we're just kind of writing
more see more and more CSS and like
reacting to changing business
requirements Kaling it on we're building
a house of cards oh my god careful I
don't have any of you I'm sure have a
lot of people have experienced this when
you go into a CSS code base and you're
like oh my god like I don't touch
anything yeah because it's gonna come
tumbling down it's so brittle this is an
actual house of cards and one of the
code bases where I work that's just kind
of been expanding over time so all these
different modifiers nobody knows what's
happening
so ah so bad fellow go from alan turing
one of our greatest difficulties will be
the maintenance of an appropriate
discipline so that we do not lose track
of what we are doing all the way back in
1945 appropriate discipline lose track
of what we are doing major consequences
okay so luckily lucky for us we have
solutions to this so we have programming
methodologies general software we have
things like object-oriented programming
agile design patterns testing
refactoring abstractions capsulation all
these things the solid principles and
then on kind of this like parallel
thinking land we have front-end and UI
programming and they have things like
design systems atomic design progressive
enhancement and all these different CSS
frameworks and naming conventions that
people have found to get these their
code bases to scale and stay or go
and these things are not that different
like there's a lot of the same concepts
but they're happening sort of in silos
and testing specifically like front-end
needs more of this so I think if
anything shows that CSS is a programming
language naming is really hard and
extremely important so our programs
where programs started out like Square
will it always be a square
probably not we kind of and then and
then renamed it to a shape it's in
everything is shape like what is life
naming ah so take care with your names
and change them when you find better
ones hmm so this is Robert Martin and
clean code so programming does not equal
logic math science and engineering those
are part of programming but programming
is writing instructions for computers
that other developers are able to read
and maintain and so this is a quote from
Phegley newspaper both writing and
programming can be described as the
translation translation of a high-level
idea into low-level sentences or
statements okay so I think a programming
language has consequences
Oh CSS has consequences and we control
them with programming methodologies
sweet okay bye
all right next friend what is the
programming language I think you can
write algorithms in a programming
language okay algorithms 101 here we go
yay okay I'll start with a definition
Oh algorithm a well-defined
computational procedure that takes input
and produces output this is from Thomas
Corbin who wrote introduction to
algorithms made you read this book this
is assigned in many an intro to computer
science class I read the introduction
so we can think about algorithms in this
format here so input unsorted list
unsorted numbers output sorted numbers
what happens in between what's the
algorithm
let's hear some sorting algorithms but I
love it that's the first one there yeah
Bob sorry / it sort merge sort
quick sort my swords okay well you're in
on the space I'm here okay
what does implementation of one of these
sorting algorithms look like named that
sorting algorithm bubble sort imperative
JavaScript so this was declarative code
all you would see is sort the algorithm
would be under the surface okay let's
think about boxes all right so stack of
boxes we need an algorithm to turn this
into a row of boxes what could possibly
be the algorithm yeah let's box this way
flex flip left gasp no no okay what what
about an implementation of this
algorithm okay nice declarative CSS hurt
I can also add some logic in here if we
want to make sure these boxes wrapped
this is what declarative logic looks
like we don't have that those control
structures we have statements let's take
a peek under the hood here so what does
flex wrap look like in the browser so
this is a little snippet from the Flex
module in servo which is an experimental
rendering engine written in rust that's
kind of slowly replacing parts of
Firefox and here's a little snippet from
the source that I think is where flex
wrap is happening so we're kind of
assigning this is wrap of all module but
this is happening under the surface of
every bit of CSS that you write and
that's pretty cool
so let's have a good iceberg metaphor I
love those all right so we have CSS on
top declarative imperative at the bottom
C++ trust oh my god so many algorithms
under here what about up here algorithms
can we call these algorithms algorithm
so my answer to this question is why not
of course so let's update our data our
intro here to CSS algorithms 101
domain-specific declarative these are
kind of the magic words when it comes to
CSS so a CSS algorithm is a well-defined
declaration or set of declarations that
produces a specific styling output and
this is my definition so keywords
well-defined and specific here and you
know what this is if you've written any
CSS before you've seen things like this
there's a little algorithm a little
original gangster CSS algorithm I'm
gonna give that a sad face this is the
first thing I thought of and I'm sad
that it's the first thing I thought of
clear fix this is a hack but this is
kind of the idea we're looking for these
specific declarations that do a thing
we're kind of all agreed upon what they
do how about this one
yeah this is cool this is really cool
this is like CSS kind of popping out of
the Dom tree and like sticking to
another thing and when you understand
that the mechanisms of the browser and
the algorithms happening under the
surface this becomes really powerful
amazing elegant or this one lobotomized
owl okay there may be another name for
this now but Hayden Pickering kind of
coined that term for this nice little
selector pattern for spacing the
children of an element without adding
space to the top and bottom or we have
stuff like this now it's kind of with
Kalkan a little bit of math so this is
some flexible text that changes the size
of the text with using a viewport unit
and then adds a balance to that size
with a little media query some linear
interpolation math and see how that's
for sure and of course CSS grid yes so
this we can create so many grids with
this oh my god so great I love it yes
that's great so CSS algorithm
well-defined declaration or set of
declarations I vote okay we can also say
a CSS algorithm is a utility pattern
that lets the browser algorithms do the
work and I think there's kind of another
aspect thinking about CSS and an
algorithmic way following some
programming best practices so single
responsibility principle we have some
kitchen tools here spoon so good at
being a spoon whisk great whisk spatula
spatulas great
okay what about a knife what about this
tool I'm going to use this fork before
spoon slash fork it's like oh you're
you're doing too much spork sad face
okay well it's a small well named
function so how small should your
functions be small and then smaller than
that so this is another Robert Martin
and clean code okay some algorithms in
the real world so you're probably not
writing the next clear fix so I work as
a design engine
here at Penske media corporation which
is a big PMC it's a big media Holdings
company so we have a lot of large
enterprise level WordPress sites some
days I'd call myself a design ops
engineer like you know do some parts
because I like my job
UI engineer another term the design
systems are another term the first and
only front-end developer another way of
describing us but not anymore we hired
another front-end developer recently and
I consider that a major mark of success
like a company that did not care about
front-end now is like oh god we need
front-end ok so the design system we're
working on is called larva not gonna go
into the story we picked that name but I
like to think of it as an embryonic
design system so it's kind of this
ever-evolving thing kind of pushed
forward with different projects a little
bit of laboratory so here is the initial
version of larva inside a wordpress
wordpress theme and so they kind of
modified IT CSS architecture so IT CSS
inverted triangle CSS so kind of ordered
by specificity and started inside this
project when pulled it out into a mono
repo now this is where this code lives
and is shared across different brands
and I had some NPM packages so when I
started the project started this initial
system inside of a project I created a
directory called algorithms and I was
like what this work like what people
actually use this me and others yes it
really worked so here are a few of our
algorithms each algorithm has a separate
CSS file which contains the actual
declarations and then some kind of
minimum HTML forward documentation and
maybe some testing later on so these
algorithms are kind of taking these
commonly used CSS patterns but
algorithms and kind of making them
system Z so making them more reusable
adding some more functionality and
making them more robust for use across
different projects and this was used 15
times in the
project mostly not by me and so I was
like okay that's a major mark of success
that's like another person can
understand this another example
space children so we also document these
algorithms in our pattern library so
other filters can come and get a quick
glance at what's going on and this is
the the space content the little bottom
eyes Dowell I'll go to them here's a
look at how we got them in there and you
can kind of obscure it or pull the
progressive enhancement out and work
with these this functionality separately
and inside the markup kind of layer the
classes in and this way so very utility
driven CSS here like an onion okay so I
think you can write algorithms in a
programming language oh you can write
CSS algorithms whoa really yes they are
domain-specific and declarative whoa
tell me more people like this and these
domain-specific declarative like that
those are the magic words okay
confusion alright let's have a storytime
how the math hater became a programmer
this is 2003 14 year old Laura I hate
math loves art classes art class and
horses and Green Day but I didn't put
that in slide so 2009 I had some blonde
in my hair and some large glasses 20
year old Laura in an art college so I
went to art school and I had this idea
for a weird video game it was kind of in
line with the prytt making work I was
doing and I was like I have to make this
game this is my mission my life and I
had a lot of freedom at college and very
supportive parents and they kind of
taught myself to code under the safe
bubble of school um fast forward several
years later I've been freelancing for a
while and I started looking for a job
and I went on this interview the title
for the job was UI engineer slash
interaction designer and I was like
awesome this is so up my alley
scientist UM's style guides UI this is
great in the interview they asked me
fizzbuzz and I was like why why would
you do that so I was totally unfamiliar
with this concept of like these
algorithms interviews at the time like
self-taught until I wrote this article
for CSS tricks about the weird
discrepancy between the job title and
the description and what the actual
interview was like and so this article
then got reposted on reddit under a
different title designer applies for Jay
s job fails at fizzbuzz and then
proceeded to write five page rant about
job descriptions and so I was like okay
so then from 2015 to 2017 I was kind of
like alright here's what I do
here's computer science whatever that
world is that's not what I do
CSS and HTML I'm like these are separate
things computer science not for me no
thanks so in late 2017
I got another job interview for a job I
was really really interested in and was
absolutely going to be an algorithms
interview I was like god dammit I have
to learn this stuff so I put myself
through this kind of computer science
boot camp and wrote a bunch of blog
posts about hash tables linked lists
bubble sort all of it
I definitely filled the interview but I
learned a lot and this kind of
separation became like wait a second
this is for me I love this and I don't
see why I was so opposed to this before
what was going on and so I wanted to
like bridge the gap between CSS and HTML
and computer science and that's when I
proposed the initial version of this
talk and throughout the course of that
talk and learning more about computer
science CSS kind of came from like what
I did for work a cool thing to being
like oh CSS like I could kind of see and
have this much greater context for what
was happening beneath the code that I
wrote and throughout writing the talk I
realized like wait this is the wrong
visualization for this the relationship
between these two concepts so no it's
more like this so computer science is
this wonderful very pleasant looking
pool and all of these languages and
concepts are within this computer
science umbrella so to put a button on
that here is fizzbuzz in CSS
okay so here we are 2019 is blank a
blank is CSS a programming language is
depression a treatable illness it's
non-binary a gender so the answer to
these questions is yes but if you ask
them it opens up the floor for people to
say no so this when I look at this now
I'm like this smells like what is going
on like of course like what yes like
what else is it so what's happening we
have these we have bootcamp graduates
like full-stack boot camp graduates that
don't understand what the Cascade is
there are companies like mine before I
started that are the designers are
building systems but can't have them
implemented because HTML and CSS are not
considered part of engineering or we
have back-end engineers and people who
might be responsible for writing HTML
and CSS in that case that don't learn
more about it because they don't
consider it programming or part of what
they do so what's going on I was
explaining this to someone at my
co-working space he's like a gentleman
in his 70s he's been programming for a
long time and I was like okay this
person definitely knows what a
programming languages let me ask him
like what it's programming language
names dick and he's like oh a language
of instructions for human interfacing
with a computer I was like yes so would
CSS be a program music yes I was like
what's going on I can explain this thing
to him he's like well are when it comes
to computer science there's an 800-pound
gorilla in the room and it's called
testosterone
so ah is that what this is is this
gender bias happening like the truth
question mark and so been thinking about
this a lot and kind of came to another
conclusion that was echoed in Tillis
talk from yesterday and and they're
talking said the route kind of a quote
here the root problem is always
capitalism if you dig deep enough and I
was thinking about this I'm like also
yes because like in an industry that's
kind of built on move fast and break
things and like feature feature feature
collect data like all of these things
like HTML and CSS fundamentally as
languages are designed not to break and
instead of like glorifying that we kind
of look at it as a we devalue it in some
way so okay but I think we need to talk
about this and think about like what why
do we not see these things as
programming and what could the world be
like if we didn't see them as
programming so CSS and HTML like maybe
there are this kind of springboard for
me they were the springboard so here's a
little baby Laura the math hater kind of
climb on the springboard here and
watches me into technology this is very
powerful I would never ever have gotten
into programming if it weren't for HTML
CSS someone with an art background but
this is not just for people that look
like me there are all kinds of people
that it's the languages like HTML and
CSS resonated with them in a different
way and so maybe these can be kind of
tools to help us diversify tech and also
the creativity not that good of drawing
people but I think we need more
creativity on our engineering teams and
more user focused these are focus
priorities so my question is like why
aren't we kind of bowing down to this
golden springboard of declarative
languages and these domain-specific
languages HTML and CSS so what is the
programming language well I think
so as some of you may have seen in the
keynote I'd open up the conference
philia and I have been working on a
survey here so at this URL which is also
going to be on my last slide so don't
open your phones yet this is a little
ranking thing so we want to see what you
think like how do you place these
languages and we can kind of spot some
trends like what's happening and maybe
think about how to how to approach this
so thank you
[Applause]